all right thank you
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the European Commission's annual press
conference at the International Green
Week in Berlin we're very happy to
welcome Yana Swarovski the new EU
commissioner for agriculture and Stella
kiriakidis the nuke EU commissioner for
health and food safety to Berlin as you
are probably aware the new Commission
only took office on the 1st of December
of last year so I'm very happy that
their first trips to Berlin as EU
commissioners are here for the Green
Week and I'll give the floor to both
commissioners first for opening
statements and then over to you
obviously for questions and answers
I wish no what you have ski thank you
very much ladies and gentlemen thank you
for your coming for our conference
together with my colleagues that are
killing kiriakidis we are new members of
the European Commission for me as a
commissioner for agriculture this is
their first time in this role on the
it's very important even which is the
international Green Week in Berlin but
in the past I had once opportunity to
participate as a member of the European
Parliament member of the vice-chairman
committee of Agriculture several years
ago now this this European green this
International Green Week this is a very
important event one of the biggest in
the world this is the platform for
promotion of the agriculture products
European agricultural production but
also this is the platform to exchange of
knowledge exchange of ideas exchange of
good practices in agriculture this is
very important
event and this is the reason that we are
both here participating in this
conference it's very important word
green in the name of this this Green
Week
we have been if face well in face of the
Green Week in Berlin but in European
Union the challenge is the not the only
green week but grineer green decade
maybe green a century because European
Green Deal this is the main priority of
the new European Commission madam
Thunder lion the European Green Deal
which is big challenge for the European
economy for the old society also for the
agriculture a contribution of
Agriculture to the European Green Deal
is is a very important challenge
challenge for our farmers of course we
yo pian Green Deal is means that we
require more from our farmers that more
requirements more we require more
environmental friendly at agriculture
more nd for the climate or fee only for
the animal welfare this is the reason
that we need to strengthen common
agriculture policy and of course there
is question of the budget I'm happy
about the initiative of the three
ministers declaration of the three
ministers of Agriculture from my name is
Elia click net from French Minister of
Agriculture and Spanish Minister of
Agriculture from December last year and
one of the question in this declaration
is that we need to strengthen the Common
Agricultural Policy and also the budget
Common Agricultural Policy we have there
now there on the table the proposal of
Common Agricultural Policy regulations
and also the budget mff our role as a
commissioner a stop to take this
proposal I protect declared the past
that I protect common agriculture budget
against the proposal to reduce this
budget but not against the proposal to
strengthen the budget and I'm sure that
we need the the serious discussion about
how to increase that how to improve the
budget and how to ensure the budget
appropriate for the big challenges
especially about the European Green Deal
green tea less chance for the European
agriculture especially for the small and
medium-sized farms and this is the for
example the biomass production this is
the chance for for European farmers and
we have to use this this chance for for
for our farmers innovation is a very
important world for the agriculture the
European the International Green Week
this is the opportunity to review the
innovation in agriculture new
technologies new methods of production
new good practices and also the common
agricultural policy should be innovative
and we propose innovative Common
Agricultural Policy the new delivery
model this is kind of innovation the
policy based on the national strategic
plans which will be prepared by the
Member States more flexibility for the
Member States but more possibility to
find good solution for the specific
situation in the Member States because
we have different situation many
subjects in agriculture between member
states different structure of
agriculture in the Member States
different needs farmers and Common
Agricultural Policy should be more
flexible
and effort the third world is security
there our farmers insure food supply
security for 500 million European
citizens the European Union has positive
trade balance about the food
twenty billion euro per year more
exported and an import but we should to
ensure security for our farmers we
should secure them they should be
secured in the future this is very
important in the Common Agricultural
Policy we have the signals than
situation is they are threats and in the
farming for example the problem of the
disappearing small farms during one
decade we lost about the four million
small farms in European Union we have
the problem with aging of the farm
population farmers population there is
in they are member states in which the
majority of farmers more than 50% they
are in aged over 65 generation
generational renewal this is the big
challenge for for Common Agricultural
Policy this is a lot of question which
we should discuss about finally speaking
about the common agricultural policy
reform this is the good situation then
now we have the Croatian project
presidency we hope that it will be big
progress in our work legislative work
and the work about the budget and the
German presidency which will be the
second part of the of the year Germany
which is the biggest member state the
biggest net appear for the European
budget and of course the
country in which there is strong
agriculture agricultural sector I hope
that this work both presidencies
Croatian and Germany will be effective
and we the end of the year we will have
the Common Agricultural Policy which
will make our agriculture more friendly
to the environment climate animal
welfare and Common Agricultural Policy
more friendly for the farmers thank you
very much just one small point could I
please ask everyone to keep the aisle
free not to stand in the aisle so as not
to block and the view of the camera
thank you